welcome back louis thorpe thinking his
fourth start of the year fifth
appearance has made a couple of rehab
appearances
for saint paul and
not sure how deep he's going to be able
to pitch in this game but as rocco said
go out there you want to see him compete
if he's throwing the ball well they'll
hopefully get him at least into the
fifth inning but really an opportunity
for him to put his name in that
conversation that we've seen with with
griffin jackson bailey ober and you know
some some of these guys are competing
for spots not only starts this year but
also
into that rotation picture next year
jose ramirez two for nine in the series
one of his two hits a double finds
himself in a 2-2 count now
he hung that one and jose blast off deep
left center field it has gone to the
bullpen and the indians will play from
in front this afternoon as jose ramirez
has just hit his 27th home run of the
season a two-out solo shot you know he
threw that slow curve ball and dropped
it in for a strike and you saw jose turn
and kind of slam the bat down on his
spikes and
try it again
two of them in that bat but then he
throws a slider and this one just
doesn't slide i mean it stays up and
right into the barrel head of that bat
and jose took advantage of it
first inning home run the indians have a
one-nothing lead and police act making
his 18th start this will be his ninth on
the road he has made knight at home he's
five and three coming off a very good
start against the tigers where he went
seven and two thirds innings just five
hits
the last time he faced minnesota was
earlier in the season they roughed him
up pretty good on may 23rd hit to the
outfield might tie the game juananoto
polanco and there's a base hit to right
field rooker around third he'll score
the ball juggled by reyes and the twins
immediately tied the game up against
blizzak polanco drives in his 66th run
well just such a simple approach up
there not trying to do too much staying
through the middle and this ball away
gets out there and pulls it but
hitting the perfect spot rooker froze
for a half second but because
reyes had to take a few steps towards
right center field he was still able to
score
three walks and now i'm guessing wes
johnson will come out to the mound it
doesn't look right to me i don't know
there's something in this delivery that
is just off and maybe wes johnson
recognized that he's gonna go out talk
to him see if he can get him locked back
in he stumbled
pushing off the rubber and didn't
complete the pitch but even the first
pitch before that he didn't look
comfortable as kind of a misfire and
take a look at it here
this was after the first pitch of the
game where he missed firing
5 or 86 miles an hour and then you see
him
this is walking off the field after the
first and just hasn't looked
right you know trying to tell wes he's
all right but
you waste that much time you you hate to
come back and throw an inning and then
go back on the injured list and when
you're competing for
your job and you're spotting the
rotation you know you work so hard to
get back out there and in thorpe's case
it almost seemed like from the get-go
something was not right and so he'll
come out of the game edgar garcia into
the game there garcia's numbers and
maybe the most important number is the
fact that he's basically a one or two
inning guy and so the twins can't handle
the ball and say all right we'll see you
again in the seventh inning so you're
gonna have to make this a bullpen game
two down back to the top of the order
mile struck but this has been a gift
wrapped inning for him see if he'll want
to walk one home
yep ball four fourth walk of the inning
two one cleveland good patient approach
by miles yeah gives him his 39th run
batted in on the year two outs three one
running brother goes and they popped in
the air to center
that's hit pretty well though back goes
gordon still going back and that carries
all the way to the wall it's off the
fence scoring is mercado and in the
second with a two out rbi double is owen
miller and the indians extend their lead
to three to one boy it didn't look like
he hit the ball that well off the bat
from the swing we saw but i'll tell you
what it carried the right center field
when halfway up the the wall
mercado was off and running he will
score make it a 3-1 game miller gets the
double his third and now mania has
walked the third hitter he sees miles
straw who has the good wheels and with
two outs we'll see if ahmed rosario
gives him that chance to get into
scoring position
deep right field down the line that's a
fair ball into the corner scoring on the
play as straw into second base with yet
another double is ahmed rosario his 21st
of the year and that's a big two out rbi
to extend the indians lead to 4-1
rosario's two out double driving in the
fourth cleveland run here's a high drive
right center field and deep
and long gone my goodness gracious
miguel stoneaute no doubter is 20th of
the year halfway up into the upper deck
in almost straight away center field i
have never seen a ball hit up there
front meal race moves open two twice has
grounded out to the third baseman
there's a ball well struck adam deep
center gordon back he's out of room it's
out of here
oh baby what a blast by fred mill reyes
and the indians now lead it five to two
arise stepping in with brent rooker at
second josh donaldson on it first
hit right field
rooker around third he'll score
donaldson digging for third and a rise
delivers the big two out hit and it's a
5-3 game tying runs on base now for
minnesota and miguelson no steps in here
to center and deep straw going back
off the base of the wall it'll tie the
game cenote to second with a two-run
double and the twins have tied it up 5-5
bringing on the left-hander alex young
said he's got nick gordon with the go
ahead run in scoring position
that's pulled down the line a wicked hop
and it goes over the glove of miller
sono around third he'll score and gordon
put the twins in front
and realton simmons the ninth man to bat
in the inning here comes his pitch
deep down the left field line
chased by mercado he won't get there
bouncing over the wall for an rbi double
gordon does score
and now it's 7-5 minnesota
a home stand with three series wins
chopper
arrives bare hands fires good play to
get him at first
louie arrives bare handing it and
throwing him out garza had thoughts of
picking this ball up but wisely allows
the rise to come in and bare hand this
ball make a terrific play
throw it on the run and then
of course you have the right guy running
straw at third getting a big lead one
down tribe down seven to five ninth
inning here's the pitch
and there's a line drive base hit center
field the indians made it a one-run game
and jose digging for two is in there
safely with a double and the tying run
is in scoring position with one out the
hustling dynamo jose ramirez double
number 25 rbi number 75. you've got
bradley zimmer coming to the plate for
oscar mercado with two down and the game
on the line here's the payoff
and it's in the back here comes the
tying run
unbelievable
he threw another one in the dirt jeffers
could not bail him out this time and the
indians have nodded the game at seven
apiece emanuel klosse on the pitch the
bottom of the knife trying to keep it
tied and sent us to extra innings
this is jake cave
behind second gobbled up by rosario
shortstop throws out cave one down
here's jorge palacco
ground ball right back to class a gets
by him and a terrific defensive play by
ernie clement to throw him out two down
here is josh donaldson
that's the cactus league express you
take the 101
to the 10th inning we've got extra
innings it's a 7-7 game and now ryan
jeffers all that stands between whit
grin and the indians moving to the 11th
inning
off the end of the back center field
diving catch by straw and that'll send
us for the first time this year to an
11th inning as the indians and twins
remain tied at seven now they're loaded
up for polanco a chance for polanco to
hit a walk-off winner for the twins
pace hit right field and for the third
time in the home stand
polanco delivers the walk-off blow
polanco does it again and the twins have
won their fourth straight series